Hey, this is  Presh Talwalkar
A version of this problem was used as an Amazon interview question
A cable of 80 meters is hanging from the top of two poles that are both 50 meters from the ground
What is the distance between the two poles to one decimal place if the center of the cable is
(a) 20 meters above the ground and (b) 10 meters above the ground
Now to be more specific a version of problem B was asked during an Amazon interview
But I've included problem A because it's interesting mathematically
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for a solution
So, let's solve the case of 20 meters above the ground
We have the ground. We have two poles of 50 meters each and we have a hanging cable. That's 80 meters long the
Center of this cable is 20 meters from the ground and we want to solve for the distance between the two poles
Now I'll admit I had forgotten how to solve this kind of problem. So I had to look up some formulas online
Many of the websites referred to the physics interpretation which involved weights and tensions
And I just wanted to get to some of the mathematical formulas
So I found a great reference
from Neil Chatterjee and Bogdan G. Nita., "The hanging cable problem for practical
applications" in the Atlantic Electronic Journal of Mathematics. I provided a link in the video description and I recommend you check it out
So we'll solve this problem using symmetry and a convenient coordinate system
First we'll split up the cable into two lengths of 40
Next we'll consider only the distance from the center of the cable to one of the poles
We can then double that distance to get the distance between the two poles
We'll also use a convenient coordinate system that's centered at the center of this hanging cable in
Other words the y-axis goes at the center of the cable and the x-axis
Also goes so that it's just touching and tangent to the center of the cable
so we want to calculate this distance x
From the paper, the general catenary equation that's tangent to the ground or the x-axis takes the following form
y is equal to a cosh of the quantity x over a minus a
Furthermore the top of the pole in this diagram will be at the coordinate x, 30
So
We can use the point at the top of the pole to get one equation
this simplifies to be a cosh of x over a is equal to 30 plus a
It'll be convenient to divide both sides by a so a the cosh of x over a is equal to 30 plus a all over a
Now we have another equation which is using the length of half of the cable
This equation will be a times the sinh of x over a is equal to the length of 40 meters
we'll again divide both sides by a to get the sinh of x over a is equal to 40 over a
Now we can use the hyperbolic identity
That the cosh squared of t minus the sinh squared of t is equal to 1 so we substitute in the values
We've just arrived and we can solve for this value of a as a quadratic equation
We get that a is equal to 35 over 3
We now figure out this unknown parameter and we can then use it in our second equation with sinh to
Solve for the value of x and we end up that X is approximately equal to 22.7 meters
Which we will then double to get the distance between the two poles as 45.4 meters
Amazing. So now how do we solve the next problem?
What if the cable is only hanging 10 meters above the ground
now suppose you try and go through the same exact method
At this point the top of the pole will be at a point x, 40
So we'll use the same equations and we'll substitute in the new values from this particular case
Now when you substitute it into the hyperbolic identity
You get the following equation and if you try to solve it you run into a problem
This equation has no solution
So what is going on?
Well, we're gonna need to think about this problem logically
The hanging cable is supposed to be 10 meters off the ground, which is 40 meters from the top of the pole
But half of the cable is already 40 meters in other words the cable must be folded exactly in half and
That means the two pole are coincident. There are zero meters apart
So our diagram is actually going to look like the following. We don't actually have a hanging cable between
Two poles we actually have this cable is going directly down
From the two poles because they are exactly at the same spot
no equations required
many employees can mindlessly calculate the answer, but how many will think before they calculate and
To be honest, I completely missed this problem because I didn't see the trick
but I'd like to make videos about these problems because it's like the old saying goes
Fool me once shame on you fool me twice...You can't get fooled again
Thanks for watching
This video I post math videos that can be watch for free with topics from people around the world because math is universal
If you'd like to help with the cause
Please subscribe for free to get the newest videos
Watch and share all of mind your decisions videos so that more people can discover the channel
Email me a math topic or puzzle at presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com
Check out my books, which are linked in the video description
And if you want to support that math is universal, please support financially on patreon
Thanks for watching and thanks for your support